さあ今回からVue.jsの内部的な動きについて見ていきたいと思います
特にレンダリングつまりUIを画面に描画するときのメカニズムについて説明したいと思います
で先に結論言うとVue.jsは仮想DOM
英語だったらバーチャルDOMというものを使ってレンダリングをします
仮想DOMとは何なのかっていうと
まずちょっとDOMということを理解する必要があるんですけれども
DOMって何なのかっていうと
これはドキュメントオブジェクトモデルという言葉の略だったりするんですけれども
これはブラウザがHTMLをレンダリングするときに使用するものになります
だからDOM自体はブラウザにもともと備わっている機能でして
Vue.jsとは直接は関係のないものになります
その上でもう少し具体的に言うと
ブラウザがHTMLを受け取ったら
それを扱いやすい形に変換するんですね
それがDOMになります
ブラウザはこのDOMを参考にして描画
つまりレンダリングをするようになっていますし
もしSnowJavaScriptでHTMLの内容を変更させたい場合は
このDOMを操作することで
間接的にHTMLの内容を変更して
描画する内容を更新するようになっています
ちなみにDOMは具体的にはこんな風に
HTMLのタグとかテキストとかが
ツリー状に構成されているデータ構造になっていたりします
またこのそれぞれの機能
節にあたる部分をノードと言ったりします
またタグを表したノードのことを
要素と言ったりもします
こういう風になっているんですね
これがDOMです
Vue.jsももちろん画面を更新する場合は
ブラウザのルールがこうなっていますので
内部的にJavaScriptを使って
DOMを操作する必要があるんですけれども
それをもう少し具体的に
どのように実現しているのか
これが今回伝えたい内容になります
その際に使用するのが
仮想DOMになります
仮想DOMって何なのかっていうと
これはVue.jsが作り出す
仮想的な
つまりバーチャルなDOMになります
どういうことかっていうと
Vue.jsは最初にレンダリングをしようとするときに
実際に書いたコンポーネントとかを
全て解析して
そこから一度JavaScriptで
仮想的なDOMをこんな風に作るんですね
これは本物のDOMではないです
あくまでもDOMのデータ構造を真似したものを
JavaScriptの世界
なので例えばオブジェクトとかを使って作ります
ちなみに本物のDOMは
JavaScriptで作られているわけではありません
例えばC++みたいな
ブラウザを実装する言語とかで
作られていたりします
なのでとりあえずこういう仮想DOMを
一度Vue.jsは
JavaScriptを使って
レンダリングしようとするときに
作成するんですね
でその後に
この仮想DOMを参考にして
効率よく実際のDOMを操作して
作り上げていきます
こういう流れが内部的に行われているんですね
まず仮想DOMを作って
その後にその内容を本物のDOMに反映させる
この流れになります
でこの流れは
アプリケーション全体における
一番最初のレンダリングのときだけに起こります
一番最初のときに仮想DOMを作って
その内容をそっくりそのままDOMに反映させる
という動きをします
がその後
例えばどこかしらのリアクティブなデータが
更新されたりして
サイレンダリングが起きたみたいなときは
また別の動きをするようになっています
どうなるかっていうと
まずサイレンダリングごとに
Vue.jsは新しい仮想DOMを
もう一つ作るんですね
その上で前回の仮想DOMと
新しい仮想DOMを
比較してその差分を調べます
なので今回だったら
このPタグが追加されているので
Pタグが追加されたなと分かるわけです
で最終的にその差分のところだけを
実際のDOMに反映させるような動きをします
これが再レンダリングするときの動きです
またこれは名前のお話なんですけれども
さっき言った一番最初のレンダリング
まだ何もレンダリングされていないときに
初めて一つの仮想DOMを作って
それをそのまま実際のDOMに反映させる処理
この処理のことを
マウントと言ったりします
またマウント後に再レンダリングが起きて
こんな風に新しい仮想DOMを作成して
前回のものとの差分を検出して
その差分だけを本物のDOMに反映させる
この一連の処理のことを
パッチと言ったりします
だからVue.jsはまずマウントをして
その後にパッチを繰り返すことで
DOMを更新するんですね
これがVue.jsのレンダリングのメカニズムになります
ちなみにパフォーマンスについても
少し触れたいんですけれども
前提としてこの本物のDOMを操作するような
処理は結構重い処理になるんですね
ただ一方でこのJavaScriptの世界で
いろいろと仮想DOMとかを作ったりする処理自体は
それと比べると非常に軽いです
なのでこの仮想DOMとかを作ったり
比較したりする処理は
全体として考えると
そこまでパフォーマンスに影響を与えることはありません
し逆にこの仮想DOMのシステムのおかげで
本当に必要な変更点だけを検出して
反映することができますので
不必要なDOMの操作は減るわけですね
なのでそういう意味では仮想DOMを使うことで
非常に良いパフォーマンスのシステムになっていると
考えることもできます
またこのパッチの時は
サイレンダリングごとに
この新しい仮想DOMを作ると言いましたが
ここも厳密にはいろんな最適化が行われていまして
実はほとんどは
全開の仮想DOMのデータを
そのまま利用していたりします
だから本当にゼロから新しく作っているわけではないんですね
ほとんどは全開のものを利用して
変更される可能性がある部分だけ
例えば二重並み括弧のところとか
ディレクティブがあるところとか
そういう部分だけをですね
再度作り直してから比較しています
なのでこのパッチの処理自体も
そこまで遅くなったりはしませんので
ご安心ください
では次のレクチャーでは
この仮想DOMをコンポーネント単位で
区切った時の考え方についても
見ていきたいと思います